608 just in this morning it's the
american lung association's annual
report card and unfortunately once again
nevada gets a failing grade when it
comes to tobacco prevention hector mejia
joining us live on the las vegas strip
with a look at just how unhealthy we are
break it down for us good morning hector
well good morning the report says nevada
is one of 22 states without a widespread
indoor smoking ban we see it here all
the time and also inside casinos however
there have been some efforts for example
park mgm which you see out there in the
distance reopened as a smoke-free casino
others have designated smoke-free areas
the organization wants a statewide
policy
everyone deserves to work and play in a
smoke-free place and not have to breathe
indoor
smoke and so what we're hoping is to
just continue those education efforts
we know we're up against a big industry
that has a lot of influence
the annual state of tobacco control
report gives nevada failing grades in
these areas prevention programs level of
state tobacco taxes coverage and access
to services to quit and ending the sale
of all flavored tobacco products however
this one's interesting the only area
where nevada scored higher than enough
is for strengthening smoke-free
workplace laws we got to see in that one
the advocacy group says e-cigarettes
still create great concern especially
among teenagers in fact the organization
also said the tobacco use rate among
high school students is way too high
here in nevada we'll go into that part
of the story still ahead in the next
half hour reporting live hector mejia
live local now